[Music]
[Applause]
andrew marchand who covers the media
sports media for the new york post
joining us on the program
how would you grade last night's
broadcast with amazon
i think dan you start off past fail
right i think
if they didn't crash they pass uh which
i know sounds kind of crazy right here
in 2022 but we were trying something
uh that was different in terms of live
streaming you know as many people we
don't know the numbers until next week
but there were millions and millions and
millions people watching this at one
time and even though amazon was very
confident and they have you know all
their web services and everything and
and it did work out there was the chance
it could crash i mean i had people very
important people from other networks
thought yeah i'm not sure it'll work
so it did so pass fail and then overall
great i'd probably give it a
a minus b plus oh pretty good okay i
thought it was pretty good i mean and
let me just say there's a caveat because
then there's people listening like i had
my screen didn't work it was terrible
for me so like
yeah like obviously i get that on social
media for my experience personally i
have no issues but obviously this is
going to be something that's a work in
progress in terms of how it comes across
on individual screens amazon doesn't
have to reveal the numbers
no they will they will uh you know the
advertisers wanted uh them to have some
sort of way to know how many people are
watching and so nielsen
will be having uh ratings but they're
not going to come out till next week
could you get that on amazon prime
around the world
no
this is just domestic so prime video is
only available in the united states
no it's available around the world but
these nfl rights are only available okay
but you are hitting on something when we
talk about the world transforming uh
that's where like the where the business
changes is when you when amazon or apple
or espn plus when they when they get all
the rights the whole world because then
you're reaching two billion people and
then you talk about subscription and
that's where kind of the world could
change over time 10 15 years
what'd you think of al michael's kerkurp
street
they're very good you know you know
here's the thing about this stuff we've
seen this with monday night football
before they just brought in joe buck and
troy aikman is that you don't want the
announcers to be the focus right and so
we're talking about how michael's
probably the greatest nfl tv
play-by-player of all time kirk herb
street the biggest voice in college
football so you know at minimum you knew
they're gonna be pretty good right it's
not gonna they were gonna embarrass
themselves at all i thought first half
energy was a little low you know alex
got a low energy because you know he
always says he reflects the game which
is when you're doing the biggest games
of the years for three decades plus it's
easy to do that let's reflect the game
when you're doing uh jacksonville and
the jets you know week 14 week 15 which
they have that one you know i know if
you want to reflect the game come on
this is awful uh so that's something
i i heard you talk about the
interception look it's al michael so
that was really i thought that was
important when amazon did especially
with that main feed they got fred
goodell who's the long time producer of
sunday night football and ended monday
night before that i
just knew that the broadcast if you
could get it on your screen was gonna be
really good and it was really good you
know like did they you know perp street
told me for a story i did that you know
he wants to be the best booth uh in
sports did i feel like it was the best
boots in sports on day one i didn't feel
that way but it was very good yeah the
sound quality bothered me it was a
little annoying to start uh muddy maybe
but
um you know a lot of times when you try
to simulate what the sound is going to
look you know be like or the you know
what the crowd is going to feel every
time i did something on the road it was
always louder than what i thought it was
going to be
and it felt like the sound level was low
but if you have people you know
that helps the familiarity of having al
call a game helps you from the start uh
herbie is familiar to football fans
carissa thompson as your studio host
what did you think of the other analysts
in there with uh the studio portion of
this
i thought they i thought there's
potential they're doing something
different if you look at the other shows
you know the espn's the cbs's the foxes
nbc lesser extent uh you know they have
older long time analysts this was a
little fresher right you know tony
gonzalez you know he was on fox and cbs
i don't really like him that much quite
honestly i don't find what he says uh
usually that moves the ball forward very
much but i thought we looked at richard
sherman we looked at ryan fitzpatrick
they had some you know good off the
field fresh perspective kind of want to
see them talking more i'm going to you
know going at each other um and then
andrew whitworth you know he has a
presence to him he's a guy who i've
heard about for years you know obviously
a great player but offensive lineman uh
who who i thought was who could be
pretty good um and so uh and chris
thompson i thought was a good choice so
i i think
here's the thing about it the pre i
don't know if many people are gonna
watch that pregame show i think the post
game show is where maybe they can make
some hay get people to hang around i
mean if you look at inside the nba you
know the most iconic studio show
probably ever in terms of uh sports um
the it's the post game that really is
where they make their bread and butter
you know that's where they have their
fun and they really so i think that's
where amazon probably has to focus on
and i think they did a good job of just
making an hour for the pregame instead
of wasting their time making like three
hours
could you see jeff bezos
trying to buy the super bowl rights
anytime soon
uh well it won't be soon but i do think
you know i i you know now i'm reading
things we were like well it didn't
transform how we watch yeah like it was
not gonna change like we just talked
about this is what amazon does they're
the best distributors of products in the
world and what they mostly do is
distribute other people's products then
they make their own in some cases but
they mostly kind of cut so what were
they doing now they're distributing the
nfl they made their own product in terms
of their booth which they brought bought
from espn and nbc and so you look at
where will we be a decade from now you
know i think next week people make a big
deal about the numbers whatever they are
uh you know amazon was promising 12 and
a half million people uh to their
advertisers
look last year and previous years fox
and nfl network are getting around 15
million for thursday night i've been
told from a number of executives both in
the league and also networks to expect
more like seven and or eight million for
next for this first time out
so the numbers won't be there but where
will they be in 10 years right and when
the next contracts are up do i think
they can be in position to get a bigger
deal get more playoff games uh they have
a chance to get a playoff game through
this through this deal if they've hit
certain numbers uh but
yeah do i think they could one day get a
super bowl i do and i think
dan you you know you're one of the
legends from espn and you know you know
and help make that what it was
in 1987 when
espn got the nfl did it transform
espn and how he watched sports i would
say yes right you could talk about 79
when it's inception but the nfls would
put esp on that next level amazon has
the nfl if you're gonna build out and
it's gonna be different than what cable
is different than what broadcast is if
you're gonna build out a sports uh
you know having live games having shows
this is where you start it's thursday
football the nfl and then you build from
there so i think when you look long term
um you know obviously the issue is
everyone's gonna have to be able
to get the stream you know perfectly and
i think people act like well that's
impossible and maybe it is i don't know
the technology but where will we be five
ten years oh yeah
so i so that's where i think to answer
your question
do i think they'll get it next contract
i'd probably say no if i were predicting
the one after that i think there i could
see amazon uh you know in in play for
that but but even maybe next contract
they have more money than anybody that's
that's the scary thing for the network
when they compete with amazon apple i
didn't know if it was a coincidence or
not but the manning cast was up
exponentially
that first week and you have a new booth
with joe buck and troy aikman
did you read into anything there
i mean i think they're like two things
number one
that's an interesting question i think
when you look at the manning cast it was
very popular last year but you could
expect growth from it because more
people know about it right like you you
know this like you left espn and a major
you know on radio show and even though
you have a big name you still have to
have people find you then they have to
you know come back again and come back
again so for the mannings uh you know
the even though they're peyton and eli
and very famous and got a lot of
publicity people have to find it so i'm
not really surprised that number uh you
know the overall espn had to be thrilled
they're close to 20 million i forgot how
long it was the highest rated you know
game that they've had and i think if the
goal was for getting the money aspect of
it and it's obviously huge money that
they they're spending they're spending
more than 50 million dollars between the
two boots for the year which is just
insane
that said
it felt bigger right it felt bigger with
joe and troy the mannings there was a
more of an aura and
what we said at the at the start with
amazon you're not talking about the
booth at least not in a bad way right
it's not did you see they they messed up
and you know they got a guy in a crane
and what are they doing that's not where
as a network the league doesn't like it
so we can talk about if that
impacts you rights and all that other
stuff it just is really bad noise if
you're running things if it's uh
everyone's talking about your booth
every week good to talk to you again
andrew thank you have a good weekend you
too thanks dave andrew marcia new york
post sports business columnist